[Music]
based on the popular real-time strategy
games story you want to build the town
into a farming center of no less than
six bars comes the film that changed the
world's expectations of video game
movies from crappy looking low-budget
messes to gorgeous looking high budget
messes baby steps you guys will get a
good one someday
Warcraft journey to the land of Azeroth
where the kingdom of Stormwind is beset
by orcs from the planet Draenor all with
the Frostwolf clan led by the mighty
Durotan have come under the influence of
gold dad and his dark fel magic now it's
up to a small band of humans who already
know the game storyline to understand
whatever it was I just said what begin
your quest through the world's most
expensive unskipable cutscenesthat's
nice to the prosthetic teeth this
actress can barely speak through her
wiles honor their tradition wait what'd
you say marvel at these artificial
characters ability to convey emotion and
these human actors inability to do the
same as you spend half the movie with
these boring ass people Lothar the
mighty warrior who gets winded walking
up the stairs King monotone the board
I'm King Lane go toasteen I'm told you
wish to talk
muddied the major always has to unwind
after a long day of magic with a nice
hot bath gomorrah the half work with a
birth defect of being kind of hot and
awe on that to drag Glenn Close into
this together they'll engage in a tangle
of plot lines about fatherhood
acceptance and the corruption of power
that will have you saying can we just go
back to the orcs please I'm bored stare
in awe at this overly ambitious fantasy
film where both sides have their own
heroes and villains that ends up feeling
like a season of Game of Thrones crammed
into two hours with six different main
characters
forming five different betrayals on each
other the Guardian has betrayed us
where is IANA Indian betraying his own
people go dan is the betrayer you should
have trusted in your chieftain all
leading up to a climax that resolves
absolutely nothing maybe they'll put a
real inning in the expansion pack so if
you love the Warcraft games where their
plot but hate the sense of humor that
made them so endearing be no sound like
Yoda you are or if you just love to
watch a bunch of dudes look at a man
supply lines hit show me where you come
from horses getting red and magic guys
covered in swirly star then according to
the box office
you're probably Chinese starring up the
main orc dude his friend the the little
mage guy look I'm at loss here can we
get a real Warcraft fan to pinch-hit for
me say no more my epic mount wait what'd
you just call me that Sarandon Lothar
lion of Azeroth and wielder of the great
sword Kells haraam a cool Dan of the
storm River clan master of the shadow
Council and warlock of them these don't
have to be so long they faithfully
reproduce Stormwind with appropriate
district roof colors and Griffon flight
path is that supposed to be important
and if you look really closely you can
see harvest golems aka the battle pet
tiny harvester of course is that even
English and the murlocs of Elwynn forest
making the iconic sound we all fondly
remember from our earliest days in Wow
nerd noob dawn of the Planet of the orcs
I can't wait for the League of Legends
movie to come out in six years too late
ooh hi honest trailer fans it's me Doug
Benson I've got a new show called pitch
off I play a fake Hollywood mogul who
fake green lights fake projects Broadway
musical version of The Avengers go
opening scene abandoned mustard factory
played by Nicolas Cage
soapbox derby to decide the fate of the
earth
alec baldwin is narrating all of this
where is he there are a hundred percent
on board with this they're at a hundred
percent I'm at zero tell me again who
the good guy is not how I wanted to
start my day pitch off only on screen
junkies plus be sure to subscribe for
more honest trailers hey screen junkies
are you tired of watching the same
boring sequels over and over again then
you'll love our new show pitch off with
Doug Benson we're comedians pitch their
hilarious versions of the sequels no one
asked for click the box on the left to
register now and watch five episodes of
pitch off or any other show on screen
junkies plus for free and click the box
on the right to check out our honest
trailer for Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
out of the shadows now on to dumb things
you force me to say why make trillions
when we can make billions it's not who I
am
it's what dude that defines me Leroy
Jenkins Larry likes looking lonely
licking lost lumpy lemon lime Wally's
gotta get a gift
gotta get a gift gotta get a gift gotta
get a gift for splinter trust me I am a
whale biologist